yeah hello welcome to this broadcast am
i late no I almost managed to be on time
maybe just a couple of seconds late yeah
I hope you all have a good monday or
almost had a good monday if you are in
Europe as I am yeah how many people do
we got in the chat let's have a look
some people online oh it's a good list
okay yes i'm going to start and just
have to get rid of that we get chat box
how do i get rid of that okay so let's
get going and playing some five-minute
games as I tend to do further on I would
also like to know some information about
this show I'm usually doing the blitz
games it's there any requests for doing
other things yeah like looking at some
some opening lines or just answering
questions or looking at studies or
whatever yeah let me know we are not
entirely tied to that blitz format I
mean I'd like to do it but there are
also other things that can be done okay
I'm playing the cross shark and it is
playing some reared chigorin Wow
Wow amazing what kind of opening lines
they're on so if i take f6 you will
takes you three yeah solving tactics
life yeah that's also an interesting
idea okay what what about this position
mmm if i move the night what is he doing
ya got a little bit distracted by the
check yeah I don't I don't want to play
a bullet in the ICC stream this is
really I mean I don't do that often
anyway and yeah I want to have some time
for for explanations and things like
that okay so what did I do with it
wasn't so great right okay i mean i
don't see a huge issue here but it
didn't feel like it felt like it had
something better and then allowing what
I actually did allow let's see lucky for
here you will probably go if I huh but
anyway now I'm not going to play entire
chest requests for three minute games um
yeah I could do that three minute is
kind of still okay it's still ok to do
in there with commentary even though it
is already a little bit out of my
comfort zone I feel that this is a bit
too quick um maybe play some e for
openings yeah I can do that it won't
help my results but I can put in some
variety sure
yeah that looks pretty equal as she
canceled on here I wonder who that is
that's a really high rating here c5 just
closing down business Yevethan
interesting okay I think we should be
two anyway and now trying to quickly
reroute the night to the g5 nigh don't
be three is just terrible yeah I'm
directly on my way to d5 with double
entendre probably completely
mispronouncing this I'll aunt on this I
can I cannot I don't speak any French
there's no info for cross-shot yeah I
have no idea where that is okay he wants
to go night f4 here hmm yeah okay I can
Castle short here after night f4 and
then go 95 so I'm going to go if I go 95
you might play quick see form Y can take
with the upon that's also not entirely
not entirely stupid or a 3 before anyway
I'll castle the other world cup final I
mean this this world kept fine i added
the way in this tournament ended clearly
shows that the this kind of knockout
tournament format is very spectacular
for the spectators but to really do
something with it that's supposed to
have any kind of value any sporting
value like decent chess games yeah i
mean this is just not happening
yeah they both were so terribly tired of
obviously that they couldn't really play
any decent chance anymore I really don't
want to I mean they're both great
players but they simply were in no
position to play good chess because they
were so exhausted especially if you
consider all those those tiebreaks yeah
there was really almost no one time for
the players to rest so I don't know it
is a it is a nice event for the for
spectators but but for the players this
is like must be a nightmare okay um what
about this he will go night queen to g5
I mean I'm sorry young takes is here and
now he takes all see takes and see takes
I'm always thinking he might go see for
at some point but he takes this f5
coming yeah my biggest yeah yes actually
the clock situation position I think
it's kind of ok not sure that he gets
some serious attack but I tend to
underestimate those things yeah a young
club is certainly up for coaching
Liverpool pretty sure he really did a
great job in the german bundesliga so
there's no reason to believe that he
would do a bad job in the Premier League
even though I'm not so much um yeah not
so well informed about current football
things someone suggest i should let my
hair grow and don't shave and no
no action absolutely no option I have so
so little hair left it looks pretty
pretty awkward so I'm setting everything
up for sacrifice on a six that was the
whole point okay maybe I should have
played Queen a for earlier mm I can go
to f1 engine sacrifice mm-hmm mm-hmm not
good any other way to get the sacrifice
in a for Bishop b5 not sure about it
home ok let's stop this this business
maybe a four a five and then trying to
prepare is he just trying to sacrifice
everything no
mmm but quadro buddies up to this ok
maybe G for now yeah it's difficult now
with my time ticking down a position was
very good for white harsher but now he
can probably do this yeah exactly this
is the problem can take h3 now and then
it's got some some discovered stuff
really ok now I've got 20 seconds quite
sure position is not clear to me at all
Jesus 6 coming that's really not
threatening much I've a blunder g5 here
okay okay he doesn't have to play good
chess anymore because he probably went
on time no I'm winning on the position
wise
my technical play with the Queen Horace
whoo okay whoo what happens um yeah
let's go next game yeah flynner with the
great definition of my blitz chess oh
yeah but i think it was good fun and I
even got four rating points out of it so
question do I invest do you invest in
stocks director to me no I don't simply
because of lack of knowledge not that I
have any specific objection they have it
I really don't um i really don't have
any specific idea there I requested a
new new game krupa okay um will you play
Cooper okay can we abort this stuff
somehow no come on I know it plays okay
let's see I really want to play the game
but send out and bored request yeah of
course I worked in a bank but I was
working in in controlling so I really am
have no idea about about the stock
markets
probably don't probably don't by
Volkswagen they have lost a ton but
probably with it loose more and rightly
so else was one of the most idiotic
things I ever heard ya manipulating the
the I mean this is this a strike
manipulating the but what is it called
the missions there is utterly idiotic
airily um yeah I worked in them in the
controlling Department being responsible
for the IT section so it's not wrong to
say I worked in our team
okay so the bad thing about my position
is I'm i have given up the bishop pal
yeah I don't know maybe you can buy
volkswagen but now with the current
stock price but i know they were so
utterly stupid that's probably more so
we have traded a bit here and i got one
Bishop away from the board but i am
pretty active so i don't think that this
is any any huge issue I are interesting
so what is he going to do if I take it I
can actually take and play rock to form
I can go rook see 195 maybe I'm slightly
more comfortable
yeah I mean I'm what I'm curious about
actually if they find out that some
other car manufacturers have done the
same thing I mean it's a little bit it's
a little bit like like the thing that we
have with the with doping in sports yeah
I mean it was pretty obvious that Lance
Armstrong always was doping because
around him everybody did take
performance-enhancing drugs and how
could he beat all those guys without the
drugs this is kind of impossible almost
and well what are the other car
manufacturers doing it they are all
playing by the rules hmm we'll see about
that from what I out that it's possible
that VW has to sell the Porsche
Department of stuff like that because
they need the cash I don't know I really
have am no expert i was just mentioning
that sometimes common sense does help i
think so um what now i'm playing McInnis
is active so i would like to trade rooks
here but I don't see how how to do that
would be nice hmm don't really see how
no idea
that's probably about equal disposition
the only has to avoid the rook trade but
this is very obvious that the room trade
is a bad idea yeah he's okay with the
draw understandably maybe I can do this
to continue a little bit but hmm no it's
the draw yeah I think you can always
lose money when you invest it
even if you feel a stock cannot get any
lower I think it can go lower there's a
question about the 2016 candidates if
they if there's a chance that aronian is
invited or would Wesley so get the
worker I don't think that this
tournament will be in the US alone I
mean I have no information but I would
find it pretty weird rexxx infield would
sponsor feed event I mean this this
would be kind of completely against
common sense or his kind of gather way
he sees things okay I'm trying to attack
that pawn
it still draws very Jewish so and if it
is in the u.s. somehow I think it would
be very difficult to explain why they
would invite anna minion player instead
of an American player I mean I would be
pretty I mean let's say it is in Germany
right ok the Germany doesn't have anyone
that could take part because of raiding
but like in general f we would provide a
pretty weird if if they would invite a
non german player would be really
strange yeah well rex sinquefield um was
part of team Kasparov to get rid of Liam
shimo so I don't think he would support
a new machine movie event it would be
would be pretty strange I mean you never
know yeah but it seems pretty strange
yeah I'm kind of just being a little bit
annoying here but I don't think I have
any really winning chance
so I can go back to c7 but I dont still
don't see what it do it what it does
still he goes now he's got rocks III
really cannot do much King be six maybe
if I go here to block it and then rook a
five then 97's at an idea maybe and
someone asks about the mathematical
implications of the Edo system that i
talked to a mathematician about that
once um yeah i don't know i don't i do
not in contact anymore with them so i'm
not quite sure i can give you any
contact data or something like that how
do i get to this i really want to try
more here not give him that easy draw
here I don't see why I don't see how
rook trade would be cool but I don't see
how to get this is this a good move I
can go to the fourth rank here and the
check that a four pole I think he
probably made a mistake here I can take
this now for the pawn
so ultimately I won 11 of the pawns
grinding away here up for a night a form
and I think no i can actually do this
winning the we need the bishop and then
we went on time by the way didn't really
pay that much attention to that no it
wasn't dr. castenmiller yeah someone
mentions the the FIFA either the blood
football association the candidates
field ever got any predictions hi right
we are complete now right we don't have
the wild card but hmm ciao I know it's
it's very difficult that's very
difficult and I think catch in schools
point is valid it depends a little bit
on wed will be held i think there would
be slight differences maybe and yeah i
think draw the current from the current
people actually i would out if I had to
bet I would actually probably bet on the
camera he only has a real bad score
against Carlton and he's really in very
decent shape so why not would be great I
mean if you ask me I would love to see
nakamura play cards and would be
fantastic fantastic for the game
yeah I have no idea what's going to host
the candidates and bioshock shweta is
right if it is Russia hard to tell would
get the wild-card really hard to tell
maybe still Kramnik I don't know now I
can i really have no idea how Boris
Yvonne off seated I think they they did
and they did a feature on that sometimes
in a German chess magazine where they
discussed some possibilities but who I
didn't really didn't really check that
much candidates in Baku yeah okay well
then it will be Mammadyarov very likely
yeah the US would be interesting and
then they would probably invite Wesley
so I mean who else really there were
other questions yeah probably he cheated
with the help of his shoes somehow even
off but really I'm not quite sure I
followed that that whole story but not
not in in big detail really the thing
that they drew that really what really
made me wonder how could you play all
those events I mean at one point there
should be some some mop of other players
simply simply kicking him in the nuts
and then he stops cheating yeah I'm
definitely sure that would happen in
some events I mean I know some players
in Germany would simply kick the guy to
the ground and make him stop playing
chess really and these are not very
violent people by nature they just hate
cheating um okay so i think i probably
made some weird decision here as a
question I can I explain what hyper
modern means yeah i can try hyper-modern
is something that or well when they
started to rethink some chess some chasm
ideas in the 1920s they called some of
that hyper modern and the the main idea
was that you don't necessarily need to
put oh isn't that using stuff I was
thinking that loses material they don't
necessarily need to occupy the center
with with pawns but you can also kind of
pressurize it with pieces or control it
with pieces it's an interesting concept
and I think um well nowadays is of
so yeah a common part of chance culture
that you don't need to necessarily put
pawns in the center however it is pretty
clear nowadays in many openings that
have been introduced back then for
example and very clearly the names of
Indian is the case in many of those
openings nowadays um quite often they
actually put pawns in the center yeah
they start with not putting them there
but later they still play D 5c five
whatever and it also means that hyper
modern it's also kind of a word for
being a bit more flexible not being so
rigid in the center so in the names oh
you develop pieces and then just adjust
to the sorry to the situation later meet
some water him wow I didn't really see
that one coming so she still cannot take
on c4 right so I know then that's 95 mm
um this two points right here what I
don't like is my my king position but
Bishop e2 is not see form I can take
this seven huh now what books do i
prefer on the Kings inion hmm there are
a couple of good books on the Kings
onion there is this some absolutely
enormous enormous now starting serious
by for serious Petronius which is pretty
pretty epic stuff but there are also
some good books by David vigorito you
don't necessarily have to
go for the Cutrone yes books yeah the
bullet gun book is also cool yeah
Lenore's right that's a little bit more
compact yeah on the news oh and bogo i
can recommend a book yeah my opponent
here wgm hooba iplayer often recently
and she's really playing well this is
the worst game that she played up to now
really blundering that piece there but
she outplayed me two times like no
tomorrow and then I really had to head
to swindle there's a question how many
books did I sell a couple of hundred i
know sorry I thought you meant my own
books am i sorry my old books that I
recently sold because I wanted to get
some new space on my on my bookshelves
um from my own I don't know actually how
many copies overall godsword I myself
sold about 100 copies yeah I have a
result good look I have good results
here after know you should stream it's
fun so yeah there's also book by Joe
Gallagher on the Kings Indian it's a bit
older like mid two thousand two thousand
four or five something like that it's
pretty good oh now we get to the now we
get to the real questions do you believe
in some kind of life after death is
death the infinite end in your my
opinion and yeah I don't know I mean who
knows
I'm not a very religious person but it's
kind of depressing to think there is
nothing right the belly none Ponseti
Kings Indian defense books a defense
book yeah it is a book that is often
mentioned but I don't know it it's very
it seems to be very popular all right
away I cannot tell I really don't have
the book seems to be a lot about
structures and things like things like
that ok I'm going to this is this a rule
of pest now it looks a lot like a room
so with just opening so I don't
understand is fluent approaches certain
moves so if you ever want to practice an
open you can't if the opponent doesn't
play the move for the opening you want
to practice yeah sure I mean you can
never force the other guy to do a
certain certain line or whatever but
well I mean why do um why do you
practice a particular opening at you
want to be ya ready for all kinds of
things that the other guy might throw at
you so we also have to be ready for the
somewhat non-standard approaches that
people play against you how much do you
spend on improving your chest at the
moment not that much I'm very much
focused on teaching and also thinking
about a new book project but it's not
really something that is very definite
at the moment so I'm working
I'm working a lot with chess not so much
on my chest it's simply a matter of yeah
how much time do you have and how much
time do you want to invest when once
let's say you have a regular day where
you work here and if you do chest the
whole day do you want to do tactics
afterwards hmm I know currently I cannot
really bring myself to do that what is
this year um it's still some kind of
spanish opening before this probably c5
coming how do i improve my pc it's not
so easy night see 8b 6 someone asked a
sharp continuation with white and the Q
Queens gambit declined Orthodox um yeah
just avoided but why would you want to
play the Orthodox play with Bishop f4
that's better anyway I guess then Bishop
g5 white never has anything in the last
car or some other lines yeah just don't
don't play Bishop g5 in the Queens
gambit declined I think playing with the
bishop air force more it's more
interesting yeah there's a question
about the possible book project yes i'm
currently thinking of of it but it's
nothing really am definite he played
this very nicely amidst Alaska wah
putting all his pieces no that is kind
of surprising I don't think that this is
so great I thought you would play this
differently okay we'll see what happens
I don't mind that so much now is Bishop
on b3 you killed his own Bishop here
killing killing your Bishop seems sounds
kind of kind of wrong right
but anyway let's put it here if he goes
look see one now I have lukes the area
using the spin on the C file yeah it
sounds like a good idea at 25,000 page
book on the English opening yeah would
you recommend tactics is the best way to
improve it depends a lot on your newest
on your skill level and your skill set I
think if you start out with chess and
for the first couple of hundred points
the most important thing is to get your
tactic straight so that you don't
blunder stuff yeah it just gives away
too much things yeah if they play if you
play Bishop g5 against the semi Slav
will bobsled and they're gonna add bt7
then then then trade on d5 simply and in
this and this move order with an early
c6 you can also go Quincy too there's
really no problem yeah you get did you
get your tactics straight if you are not
that high rated to make sure that you
don't blunder stuff yeah it is really
too much of it bleeds too much points20
points away if you blunder material so
you have to get that straight but after
that if you reach like 1800 1900 or
something then you need to make sure
that you also learn some strategic play
and games and so on um okie dokie what's
happening here I'm going to trade and
see what happens here Queen to be 6 I
guess
I just said that there was a questioning
and about the possible book project and
I just said that I'm thinking about it
but I have not made any definite
decision if I do it at all on and what
exactly I'm going to do you have a time
when doing a book it will be an opening
book that's clear I'm not doing a
something on chess training or so as I
will do openings but what exactly as I
said is unclear and even the the general
thing is not entirely clear if I will do
it at all it's tons of work really and
it doesn't really help to start a
project and you know that you cannot not
managing it so I'm only starting this if
I really feel like I can complete a book
in in somewhat somewhat decent time okay
hmm Bishop d3 3d one that summer was not
leading to much maybe that wasn't great
and I'm sitting in some kind of self
pinned down this Bishop to Bishop d2 is
probably just a draw well I'm not only
Garcia really thinking about doing
something a millionaire Chesser that's
cool
oh he gives me the pawn I'll take it
it's said that's a question is there
anything else and doing puzzles on on
chest tempo to improve tactics mmm well
the thing is you can do many things of
course and tactics is not tactics I mean
you know there are different forms
there's some this thing yeah just
solving short move from short move
puzzles let's say one okay what's this I
do here how do I get get do I get this
pawn rolling somehow if I play this no
okay I'm chime checking maybe then here
and trying to go for be three once I've
to hanging that would be heartbreaking
but I think that ultimately will do the
job here i go i get to t4 and b 2 and so
on and have some optimism also regarding
the clock so now somehow it's still not
winning yet this is kind of kind of
weird okay i need the king I think I
need the king
okay yeah I'm somehow scoring well here
okay so um so okay what can you do you
can do the short term the short move
puzzles but you can also do some good
more complicated things um yeah so like
complicated position and analyze them
you can also analyze um your own games
don't use the computer if you work on
chess and simply switch off the computer
then it's very helpful sometimes because
you get to think on your own so there
are there are many ways to do it but if
you are 1900 on Chester both the guy who
asked the question it's not so bad
already there the question what to
recommend against the sloth defense who
many things i think mr. vast jerk-off is
not playing the Slav so we cannot
demonstrate that I like the night f2 and
Queen see two lines or queen bee three
lines there's a question no I'm not a
second to anyone they don't know what
people like white a shack and Peter and
he doesn't get paid I know that what
people tell me that have worked as a
second like him young gustafson for
example I spoke to Peter lake oh um it
was last year right I should two years
ago um and he worked in the in the team
for four vishy anand for the world
championship match 2013 and it is tons
of work I mean tons of work and it's
something that should be paid well
because it seems to be yeah it's tough
so um what about this I'm playing this
lining against this safe game you've
asked your coffee this guy's more than
80 years old and still
pretty much kicking here in blitz chess
so all of you guys who are still young
dynamic yeah don't forget there's you
can still play decent chance when you're
older it's it what's the question what
is the worst opening that is playable
hmm that's difficult question yeah
someone mentions what's jordan Spieth
caddy made I don't even know who jordan
Spieth is i think is this you want some
some major golf avenger probably not
much into golf the worst opening that is
playable hmm that's a fine line right so
kind of what is not really great but not
terrible difficult difficult to same I
mean you you always have kind of
revaluations that if you would have
asked her like maybe 20 years ago
someone would say the Dutch defender and
nowadays the Duchess kind of respectable
so r oopsie 8 so what am I doing here I
can think about different things I
wonder about my king position maybe I
should really play rook e1 Bishop f1
secure stuff one night f 1 93 not quite
sure yeah I'm a porn up but black some
peace Oedipus of course pretty active
what is he going to do putting something
on one-on-one g4 okay I'm I wish I vm
conservative him yeah what's your covers
real legend yeah he played against
everybody yeah from Fisher to ya
botvinnik whatever yeah i mean really
amazing an amazing career auntie em he
also know is an excellent excellent
blitz player he's known to have one
stuff like that the moscow blitz
championships and stuff and i can assure
you that the moscow blitz championship
is pretty pretty strong
so hmm okay that wasn't really what I
wanted how do i play a 92 I can
goodnight no I cannot I think I'm still
kind of okay yeah yeah this is flood up
brings the story let's indeed true i
think the legend is that Fisher that I
think 15 year old a sixteen-year-old
Fisher was in Moscow to play em to play
in the in the Moscow chess club and he
crushed all the people there in blitz
and they had to bring in Tegan Bedrosian
to to bet on the young Fischer and
Petrosian really a managed to to beat
fishin okay um so if i take g5 then is
going Bishop h2 which loses stuff if i
go 93 my play Bishop is six anyway not
much choice this should be six i wonder
if there are some discover detects no he
just lets me take a five that i didn't
really expect i cants not a huge deal
let's take this one point is night c4
it's kind of important but he has many
of things unprotected i wonder if
there's some kind of tactic quincy three
maybe let's do that
you had the most hopeless Championships
is pretty cool I guess if you do well
there you will probably do good in the
do well in the world blitz but how does
he keep his stuff together here now I'm
taking this and this you're a little
tactical swindler yeah Mr Vasic off
Queen B 6 bishop age too ha ok let's
cover the stuff and see what he's doing
now probably night c4 huh shoot I should
have thought about this a little bit
more I can take them but still not be
too oops no Luke c6 is not working and
checking checking doesn't help ok
so I think I'll get the a six porn as
well I just wonder I mean my
coordination is slightly off for the
moment but this is a position that can
be can turn to be really good but can
also you can also pretty much fall apart
quickly so what now I think I should go
for stable positions night Bishop to d4
Knight to f4 think I'm pretty ok here
unless you find some direct way of
attacking me that's certainly possible
like he and checking me all the way it's
not attacking something here at the
moment the night is protected
let's give this check and now maybe
march the pawns cold is rook is not
doing that much I don't do the endgame
puzzles on chest tempo I tried that once
but they were kind of weird at the time
and I stopped stopped doing them what I
mean is um it was a case where you you I
mean it was like a table base stuff and
I didn't like that very much hmm I mean
there was just like one solution and at
some and some I mean how can I explain
that there was pursued ever positions
back then when I tried maybe this has
changed but when i tried the book
positions where I'm I'm name and would
actually give you points only for the
perfect move so if you had a winning
eight moves you had to play that route
and if you only find the winning seven
moves it was wrong and this is this is
just [ __ ] sorry um and well I
stopped doing those puzzles because I
felt it was just too too frustrating Wow
okay now he has to take the only move
do I have some perpetual or not I mean I
just did this one principle because I
didn't see any other continuation well
it seems seems like a draw I offer him a
draw here offered twice yeah he managed
to take it yeah I would have one on time
but what what kind of games that if you
win this is all time um so I ok so they
change the format down chest tempo for
the for the end game trainer yeah ok
that makes sense that you did they give
you still points for the second best
solution back then that was really weird
like the wrong all wrong and this this
happens all the time that you don't find
the most efficient efficient way
meet our boy soul or something am i
actually unbeaten in this session I'm
kind of curious about that let me check
yeah I haven't lost yet that's good and
I really wondered yeah if I could do a
good job I've been doing my taxes for
two hours before that session which is
simply one of those dreadful experience
as ever right doing your taxes what can
be worse I really thought okay I'm going
to play total nonsense after this but it
seems to be kind of okay at least so um
hmm maybe night a four-year in this
position that's an idea
yeah I really only play in the pool no
rematches maybe i can i can pre move
that so you're saying that this is a
good porn structure I don't believe you
Knight takes a 5 GF yeah what's now
we'll just give three yan I don't know
I can also play this very technically
taking and playing see form
yeah Texas and Germany are a complete I
complete mess it just it just really it
just sucks on so many levels so um let's
think about this here he will get in d5
anyway to TX takes Jim the kind of
position where you will always be
somewhat better but question is how much
i think i'm going to flick this and so
he has to play the King first that make
some sense Queen f6 I'll take d 6 so he
has to play the king bag hmm and now
it's there I don't know is if oh I good
move take screen txt five probably not
mmm yeah but this is very weakening home
so what do I do here probably maybe it
doesn't matter though so much that's
certainly possible okay let's try to get
at the Deaf 5.1 now with rookie one look
t 4 and so on piling up on the deep on I
think you can can still improve from
after the after 30 the question is
really how much are we how close have to
come to your on let's say for fulfilling
your potential if you want if you didn't
really work that hard on chairs before
that age like 35 or whatever and then
you all of a sudden have much more time
available are you willing to waste more
time whatever then you can can still do
things yeah I'm pretty sure about that I
really see no particular reason who I am
this shouldn't be possible
yeah the interesting question Candace
can I stay can I stay unbeaten here
my poor is not playing here why some
kind of technical issue I don't know see
fire okay i am not quite sure that this
is any good give me a couple of points
to look at
you see grabbing that pawn and it's
possible it's possible
you can try to grab a 2 and like yeah
grab the money and run this kind of
attitude but it will be risky oh that's
a cool move I didn't see that one coming
I mean I wanted to go here to make sure
nothing bad happens to to the e to pawn
but
and would be difficult to play this
position for a winner believe as a
question is amateur to m by john hawkins
good and this is one of those cases i
have that book but never never studied
it i I got it maybe I intended to use it
in my in my with my students but I never
really got going around using it it is
not exactly easy material and most of my
students are not strong enough to to do
this kind of stuff huh yeah you have to
go to g8 anyway or not is there really a
big choice iam
and I can almost pre-move look at five
him only one day of this if he can he
really use them so check here okay but
if I go then okay maybe I've lost you
but what can I do I currently don't see
it I think I'm actually surviving the
checks but maybe I'm wrong here kingi
one Queen g1 King to rook the edge rock
t5 I don't see it
and there's a question by bio Schweitzer
what it is necessary to really to do
really hard stuff with the trainer 2,300
plus and no um the thing is I have lots
of material that I that I do use with
the with the strongest students and I
never really got around to using Hawkins
book oh I actually lose now with you
three or not I can go here maybe do I
survive this I didn't calculate any of
that if I survive it it's just pure luck
I have to I mean I other moves lose here
mmm yeah it's only move I can take and
take you three actually this is not
completely out of the picture Queen C to
D and check check check check don't see
it show me why this losers where looks a
bit awkward between why is it losing I
am he goes them okay now i am taking
that porn him
so let's see where where to go I really
want to get out of those bloody checks
22
quindi five no now let's do this for
Queen g5 why not grab a new pawn on
additional porn let's say yo that was it
was tricky very very tricky did I miss
something I don't know probably but I
still want that ok I think I'm going to
go for one more now I don't know how it
is in the Blitz and rapid what what what
what what you can do that in terms of
how near you can get to the players and
such I have no idea I'm curious myself
I'll me now I'll go visit them I'd
important thing before I forget I'm not
online next week next monday i'm not
doing a show because i'll be in Berlin
um to watch the rapid and bliss
championships so no witch knows show
next Monday um but I can tell you that
right away that I'm going to do a show
tomorrow um I'm going to do a show
tomorrow on my own twitch channel um and
not quite sure what i'll be doing can be
anything not necessarily blitz bullet
whatever can be something else i'm not
sure yet but it will be online tomorrow
definitely on my own channel
yeah always do like a couple of minutes
extra I don't I don't know who is I
don't know who is participating why
don't answer it kind of weird today with
my my language so I don't really have a
information about the participants of
the world rapid and blitz I think Magnus
Carlsen's playing but many air players
are missing because of that million HS
event bit of a shame that is there is
some colliding the dates but what can
you do
so I'm just developing stuff hmm maybe I
should have played nicely for
immediately would have been interesting
but okay I think I'm I'm kind of okay
pieces are active and b2 is hanging
Carl's and Ireland Greece should be one
choker una kayaking cromley cool yeah it
will be a cool line up in Berlin
Nakamura kawana so huge ng Liam jam jam
would be better if they would
participate but what can you do yeah
it's not so easy by the way here for the
four YTM this position so what am I
doing here 95 and i think i'm going to
increase the pressure here my tiguan
sephora we cannot actually okay yeah I
think God's is the favorite for that
event as usual I can can play a four
year huh
and that runs into Roxy too right Quincy
seven doesn't really help a lot and
bloodshot I am that's also possible
that is also possible for sure mmm jam
the sixes kind of hanging a little bit
yeah there's a question I wonder if they
get Grandmaster Kumar off to commentate
on the world blitz that's cool yakima
roof was a great commentator in that for
that dubai event he's a nice guy by the
way I've got to know him a little bit
when I played my GM event um in Majorca
and now in February it's really friendly
guy so what happens here I think I can
do this going in for some technical
tricks 26 rook g8 twin c4 c5 yeah i'm
not good at tactics and sometimes I see
little tricks sometimes oh come on are
you I see taking a 4 have a trick myself
hmm
and I'm not sure don't think it's that
bad maybe I should have played that
quicker and kind of suggests okay yes
I've played Kumar off in that event but
it is um it wasn't a real game I mean it
was the kind of game where he played the
most boring opening ever and my event
was already kind of spoiled and then he
offered to draw like after ten moves or
so and I really rather had a walk on the
beach then sit there for hours um so
what here rock chicks I guess so Quincy
to feels it feels pretty active so i'm
not sure that i really need to lose this
game so maybe I can stay unbeaten in
that session I wonder if he can maybe
can do some kind of attacking ideas or
mom on my king word
I think you can buy tickets at the site
of oberlin I haven't I didn't buy any
tickets yet i will just buy them when
i'm there not quite sure that will
attend on all days and for what times
and whatever i also want to do some
sightseeing in berlin
so can I actually keep my pawn there
with this or is that risky stuff maybe a
bit home I'll try
and for maybe I know it feels kind of
risky for what my activity is not so bad
oh thats gets interesting yeah but this
is what does it accomplish I don't quite
understand I mean I can certainly take
this year right Bishop I can take this I
believe I don't get it did this is
really help white I mean I don't believe
it what is your queen doing now mr.
Scott Queen g5 or what I can check here
and then see what can I do Queen age
free he only has a check there so I it's
got Bishop f4 maybe
don't see you win here unfortunately you
should have form not sure
and I can threaten queen age three it's
pretty big threat yeah he forfeited on
time but i think it's it's a win right
don't see it yeah what is your queen
doing now mr. Scott is that a Bond
villain impression someone said I'm not
so bad and in the Bond villain I don't
know I probably need a how was this God
else Blofeld yeah with that cat and so
on it's quite funny okay guys um end of
stream we are already 17 minutes 17
minutes overtime I haven't lost a single
game that's pretty pretty cool I mean I
had head streams where I lost like or
games so that was good okay i hope you
enjoyed it make sure to join tomorrow I
think it will it would start maybe nine
in the evening German time center Europe
in time something like that yeah and no
stream in one week yeah no stream next
Monday thanks for watching bye bye
you